some of you guys may remember that they
had a warning label at the end of their
advertisements that said if an election
lasts longer than four hours you know
must contact a medical professional
right and so the beauty is there was a
genuine risk but in making the risk they
amplified the power of the product every
single guy heard that warning and was
like i could have an erection for four
hours sign me up right and so it would
be like the same thing as saying like
warning when you sign up and start
working with gymloc you're going to
massively increase your tax burden so
like we are not liable for the amount of
taxes that you're going to have to pay
as a result of the amount of money we're
going to make it's the negative
consequence of the positive that
amplifies the believability of the
statement if we're warning people that
the extreme adverse effects of the
result that we're promising in an
extreme fashion then it makes the
underlying believability of whether or
not they're going to achieve it seem
assumed this is one of my favorite
persuasion tactics